he's a man named Duke who went to Yale
where he learned on the acting
profession that has now brought him to
an incredible first feature film
performance in a film called black
panther I think we've all heard of it
that has already made over two hundred
and sixty million dollars at the
domestic box office the man who plays in
Baku who we just saw tangle with Black
Panther played by Chadwick Boseman so
many people know from his role in forty
two is playing Jackie Robinson we're
thrilled to have Winston Duke here on
the show good to see you Winston thank
you what in the world has life been like
for you over the last week's time Oh God
the last week has just been just
honestly incredibly surreal and the
experience of making this movie was also
surreal because I would have been happy
and lucky to be in a movie with just one
of these guys and now it's Angela
Bassett is Chadwick Boseman Lupita
Nyong'o and the reception of the film
has been out of this world I'm from
Trinidad and Tobago yes sir
and they did when it premiered it
premiered yesterday in Tobago in the day
before in Trinidad and they did they had
drummers big drummers celebration
dancers a beauty pageant associated with
the premier were you there I wasn't
there I wasn't able to go I was doing
all this press here sure but you know my
spirit was with them you know I hear
people have just been responding writing
me a lot of notes on all the social
media platforms just saying how much the
film means to them and means to their
children how so give me an idea on that
front one well first of all like what's
really what's great about this film is
that that makes it really different is
that people aren't just committing to
seeing it once twice three times they're
actually gifting the film they're
gifting it to communities and they're
gifting it to after-school programs in
their you know their kids and groups of
children and they're buying out theaters
to take their kids and they're they're
able to see that you know their kids are
watching people who look like them in
the media you know children of color are
seeing themselves reflected and
their hopes and dreams reflected in a
way where the people in front of them
aren't people who are coming from a
place of just struggle or being poor or
being in pain you know Black Panther is
a king he's a politician he's the leader
of his country
sharee is you know an inventor she is in
control of the country's technology you
know what I mean everyone is powerful in
their own right and they stand on their
own
you know they stand on their own laurels
the woman in the film aren't defined by
some male gaze or masculine lens they
define how they interrogate their world
and how they hold their world
accountable so it's great for little
boys little girls families can just have
fun with their kids and then engage them
with really great conversations when
they get home people are dressing up and
you know an African inspired attire and
it's just really something special it's
become an event of its own so there's a
movie and I keep saying there's just the
event around the movies just something
that's remarkable Winston Duke here on
the Rich Eisen show how did you first
get involved in this so well I got it
you know just like most actors go
through the process of auditioning so
probably three months before I started
working with some new agents and they
met with me and they said what do you
want what do you want for your career
and I told them you know I want the work
that I do to have a social justice and
impact impact footprint associated sure
so even if it's in this huh in this town
there's just so many really great
creative people who want to make a
change sure and it doesn't have to be in
the way that you expect I mean even
franchises like you know fast and
furious or something that really have a
lot of diversity yeah said I really
commercial also have that it's showing
just different slices of life so I said
hey I want to be part of something like
that in I respect Ryan Coogler so much
the director yeah I said I love his
voice I love that he knows who he is and
I love that he knows what his aesthetic
is and
the kind of stories that he wants to
tell and the impact that he wants to
create on the world I see that just in
Fruitvale and Creed and I said this guy
is a guy I would want to work and then
couple months later I'm going in for a
black panther and for auditions later
over maybe three months
I'm mbaku and in the cast as you
mentioned Forrest what just just
throwing something out there you
mentioned Fruitvale station obviously
Michael B Jordan Chadwick Boseman of
Angela Bassett who is a legend legend
okay certainly ever since she got her
groove back
Farah Winston from Forest Whitaker being
one Martin Freeman another Daniel Kalu
who's nominated for an Oscar in Oscar
Ferg afta forget out as well and then
Lupita Nyong'o who you know she's an
Oscar winner from 12 years of slave yes
but you went to school you went to Yale
with her yeah we were at Yale School of
Drama getting our masters and Fine Arts
together right and it's a very you know
tight-knit small community intimate
space she's one year ahead of me and we
were both part of a group called folks
that angela bassett when she was at the
program he's set up during her tenure
ship there and you know we got we became
really good friends and we'd go see
movies and things together in one of the
movies was Avengers and we're just young
kids before 12 years of slave before the
Oscar before everything yeah which is
young artist going do you think we'd
ever be in a movie like this do you
think this could ever happen this is you
know what I mean and now our first big
Disney thing together is this is within
that universe I believe uh-huh yeah I
mean what if you do what if we had told
you mmm
that night when you walk out of the
movie theater there's something gonna be
called Black Panther you're both gonna
be in it it's gonna be the 18th film of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and it's
gonna make the most money out of all oh
I don't think I could ever I think I
could believe it but I how it manifests
you you never know the idiosyncrasies
that you know right how it's gonna
develop and that's really what this
movie is and the event around it is we
knew that we created something special
right and we fought every single day and
to be honest it stopped being a movie
really quickly while we were shooting it
it became a labor of love really quickly
for us but we knew we had something
special we fought every day to make the
story mean something everything make
sure that it was grounded in some
reality even though we're using these
vehicles of you know of comic book
characters and really heightened
characters to tell this story but we
wanted to be rooted at every turn and
something more and we fought very hard
to make sure that this was a strong
story coming out of it but to know the
impact so the intention was there but
the impact is just something so much
more yeah and you're already reading I
mean I'm already reading about the the
history of the script and how the first
one was the earth thoroughly rejected
and now it's we we obviously see what I
did what it is and what it has become
let's get down to brass tacks Oh sequel
what are we talking I don't know wait
and see on that one I don't know
anything about that one you're right
yeah what about any the infinity Wars
would affinity Wars you could see mbaku
again and Avengers infinity war okay
okay that's good yeah I like that and I
couldn't help but notice this when you
said that that the premiere of the film
in your your home country of Trinidad
and Tobago Tobago got it first straight
I got it first bago yeah could could
could debate could Tobago get first and
we've also bigger Islands Baku Bob what
I'm just saying is there is there you
know like a Tobago can't they get top
billing ever I mean you know Trinidad
and Tobago you save you know how about
this can Tobago and Caicos yeah that
would be like a movie right yeah Caicos
and Tobago gets since the world
it all goes up against Turks and
Trinidad Mary that's funny
that at the next meeting I'm trying to
get in on this goldmine
let's do a thing with k-cups is it true
that you and Daniel Kula will have an
idea about a reboot is that was just
stuff one of those like speedball fun
questions like hey Winston
what would your favorite ruby boots you
know dream read would be and I said
rebooted have bad boys with Daniel Kuya
okay what's a noob and Daniel Cleary
that's all I said
all right yeah and a man if we're making
dreams come true I love Bugattis okay we
like Bugattis so what are you what are
your favorite is that one of your
favorite Will Smith movies I love
everything that Will Smith has ever done
even you know what was that god
something degrees of separation was it
okay for separation one of his first
like made films you know I've loved
everything about him but bad boys is
just another iconic film you know with
strong acting and really great storyline
and people love to consume okay well
look you're making it seem like I'm
pitching this thing now well you're
you're doing that uh Winston I you know
I know you've had a good week but here
at the ridge and show we like to make
dreams come true okay well good to see
you man congratulations on your meteoric
success and good luck on black panther 2
which I do believe we found out he's not
allowed to talk about but it's gonna
have okay we just found that is just
putting words in of Tobago in Trinidad
which is good to see he's coming for us
he's coming for us thank you guys and
and we'll never forget that time that
you and Lupita went to that harvard-yale
game and just stick
yeah he's actually yeah he's wearing a
suit under that's exactly right black
panther in theaters near you if you
already did not know good to see you
when Winston underscore Duke to follow
this man on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience